Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah dj oooh
[music]
me
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Your philosopher's stone's unique ability is slamming
tan
but you can't accelerate during free fall That's it -
Glasdale's attack is inferior
It makes you fly  Invites a free-fall attack to
catch it like this French thick soup
first stage is safe
This is the real me next
I can die as it is
I won't be caught by my favorite form rush
Kiss moga ni no yai yatsu Who
should do it is the world of death 20
Don't die,
dare
tan
goo
dare, you
're a monster You're still alive
Don't move, no, this house
killed Jesus Borrowed from the cleaning of Antioch You're
a good philosopher,
even if you don't drink a lixil and give up being human The
philosopher's stone itself is used to kill Ulysses  Ulysses can be manipulated as a
stem.Any part other than the brain can be regenerated, but
the organs stolen by this guy can't be
cured.Using side-by-side running as a weapon, I will exterminate monsters that should perish from the human world.That's
me.  O hunter of Ulysses